I don't think it's had a dramatic
effect.
I think one of the effects,
which is not probably a great effect,
is that a lot of the new shows now try
to show that they have a sense of humor
and uh,
and um,
um,
that,
that they can be rascals as well or make
fun of themselves.
And I'm,
uh,
I'm not sure how I,
I,
I'm,
I'm not sure how valuable that is.
I think probably their anchors on these
shows are less likely to say things
without thinking if,
if they're concerned that they might be
made fun of on a show like the daily
show.
So that can't be bad.
I don't think it's made the gun gun shy
in a way that the,
that the audience isn't being served.
I mean,
um,
you know,
I think,
um,
I think that the,
the,
the sad reality remains that they are,
that they respond to what they think
their audience wants.
And this current campaign is so riveting
that they're sort of on their best
behavior right now.
And I actually think that the,
that,
the,
that the cable news nats,
which are sort of flawed because they
feel that they need to keep filling all
this time least it's being filled with,
with more substantive politics than
usual.